[Música]
[Aplausos]
crecí en una familia de 12 hermanos si
escucharon bien 12 hermanos una familia
de recursos limitados donde la mayoría
del tiempo la respuesta era no hay
dinero adoptando hábitos y pensamientos
que te limitan y hasta te bloquean les
ha pasado que van por la vida con
algunos comportamientos y se han
encontrado preguntándose por qué hago lo
que hago en mi caso mal manejo del
dinero miedos hábitos alimenticios esto
pasa porque el 95% de nuestros
pensamientos y acciones son hábitos
automáticos que hemos aprendido y que la
mente ha decidido que no merece la pena
dedicarle esfuerzo mental así como ha
sido programada nuestra mente podemos
reprogramar la con nuevos modelos de
pensamiento la mente bien utilizada es
un regalo divino nuestra comunicación
interna determina todo lo que nos pasa
en la vida
tenemos 75 mil pensamientos diarios en
promedio si la mayoría de esos
pensamientos son negativos como van a
ser los resultados de ese día debemos
ponernos a dieta de pensamientos tóxicos
y cómo lo hacemos
reemplazando pensamientos negativos por
pensamientos positivos la persona con la
que más conversamos a diario no es con
nuestros padres o con nuestros amigos es
con nosotros mismos nuestro mundo
exterior es un reflejo de nuestro mundo
interior hasta preguntas constructivas
que estimulen el entusiasmo y las ganas
de hacer lograr tus proyectos prueba a
preguntarte cuántas nuevas oportunidades
puedo tener o cuánto puedo crecer como
profesional
aquí el nivel de satisfacción puedo
llegar
prueba el poder de la visualización
cerrando tus ojos en un entorno
tranquilo y visualizando aquellos
resultados que deseas ver en tu vida
cómo te sentirías y consideras esas
metas experimenta el orgullo y otros
sentimientos en ese momento visualiza
cómo lo celebrarían la mayor parte del
tiempo estamos esperando el momento
perfecto para pasar a la acción cuando
los hijos sean grandes o cuando tenga
más dinero y de este modo posponemos
proyectos y objetivos importantes no
importa las creencias los hábitos o el
entorno en el que hayas crecido tú eres
el dueño de tu destino sólo basta
decidir tomar las riendas de nuestra
vida apagar el piloto automático en que
a menudo tenemos nuestra mente para
vivir una vida diferente muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]